- Let's do this.
- Sorry, let's do this.
(light clapping)
(clapping)
We're back on track.
(unusual music)
(clock ticking)
- Let's do this.
- Okay, I'm Ola.
(upbeat music)
So much.
- I need to stop watching
Friends on repeat and
watch some new content.
- Big Mouth.
- "ig Mouth.
We love Big Mouth.
- We love Big Mouth.
- Knock, knock, who's there?
It's the hormone monster.
(laughing)
- And Schitt's Creek.
I love Schitt's Creek.
- I'm obsessed with this.
- I would take off my
shirt and, like, throw it
at those guys but please don't do that.
I won't do that.
- Go, tell someone
you love them
by flashing them your tits.
- Jesus Christ, that's
some awful, that's awful advice.
Who said that?
Weird.
(bell trilling)
And you, obviously, like--
- Obviously.
I trust you.
- Yeah, I trust you.
- I really trust you.
- Okay, that's a good question,
we've answered that one.
- Yeah.
(bell trilling)
I'd be in Modern Family and I would
take over the role of Phil Dunphy.
- Love that.
- Because he is one of the greatest
male characters of all time.
- You know, this is so stupid but, like,
this is the first thing
that came to my head
was Power Rangers and I
can't stop thinking about it
but I'd be the red Power Ranger.
(grunting)
(exploding)
- Power Rangers: Rebooted,
starring Patricia Allison.
- As a red Ranger.
(bell trilling)
- I'm a binger.
- [Patricia] Yeah.
- Its nice when you find a TV show,
like, years after its been out.
- Yes.
- So, then its, like--
- Then you can do that, right.
- Then you're, like,
I'm currently in the process
of re-watching Buffy The Vampire Slayer.
I mean, I watched it when it came out
and I was young--
- This is a fun thing.
- But I was young and I didn't, really,
know what was going on.
- Yeah.
- My mum watched it and I,
just, was there, really.
But, now I'm watching it properly
and its, like, yum, yum,
yum, I'll have, like,
one episode while I eat my dinner, today,
and then, yum, yum, yum, I've
still got 300 episodes left.
Sarah Michelle Gellar.
(lip smacking)
(bell trilling)
Snack.
- Obviously, I mean, I don't wanna be
the first to say it but popcorn.
- Popcorn, copporn.
I love popcorn.
- Popcorn.
- Salted popcorn.
- What?
(laughing)
- Party Rings.
(bell chiming)
For those of you who don't know,
is a English delicacy.
- Tiny biscuit.
Its nice and round.
- Found at children's parties, mostly,
they are little biscuits--
- With holes.
- With icing on them,
with hole in them, I once ate a whole
packet of Party Rings, during the first,
before the opening credits of
RuPaul's Drag Race started.
♪ RuPauls's Drag Race ♪
♪ May the best woman, best woman win ♪
- Oh, okay, whoa, whoa.
- Yeah.
(bell trilling)
- Four.
How many with you?
- I think, five, that I know of.
- Innit, like, you don't know.
- Sometimes, though--
- Sometimes people just
slip the password and--
- You go onto, like,
the section where its, like, recent logins
and sometimes there's some, like,
crazy places that come up.
- Really?
- And I'm, like, messaging my family,
like, has anyone been in Gloucestershire?
Gloucestershire, is that a place?
- That's a crazy place.
- Gloucester.
- Go to some crazy places.
- Crazy places, Gloucester.
- Gloucestershire, gosh.
(bell trilling)
It depends.
- Yeah, it really depends.
- It depends on what mood I'm in, as well.
And Big Mouth, I have to not skip it
because they always do these songs.
- I like it when Coach Steve
sings the opening credits.
♪ I'm going through changes ♪
- Just love Coach Steve.
We're promo-ing the wrong show.
(laughing)